hello please bear with me while I get
our live stream started for our LinkedIn
live audience
will take me a couple of moments
one moment please
okay and Welcome to our LinkedIn live
audience our YouTube live streaming
audience and of course everyone here on
WebEx
and
my name is Stuart Creek I'm a marketing
manager here with simply learn
let's get started with our
program
so we will be talking about how to
become a business analyst in just six
months
with IIT verb key
and
just double check here
I have Professor turn Sharma here with
us and he will be helping me go through
the presentation
um
hopefully we'll be joined by Professor
I'll meet soon
but welcome Professor Sharma
um you're on mute I think
damn hi Hi how are you I'm great
and uh I just want to let the audience
know this is
kind of a little last minute change for
us we had another professor from IIT
rookie who was lined up so we're very
grateful that Professor Sharma can join
us at this last moment
um so let's get started we're going to
talk about
the agenda when I say about you we'll be
asking you a few questions along the way
so please be watchful for the polls to
come but we'll be talking about business
analytics careers
why they're so important in the world
today and such a good option for people
then we'll talk about what this program
offers how it gets you job ready
and
versus how to enroll in it
um so we're talking about business
analytics careers and Professor Sharma
I'm going to ask you to ring in on this
as I go through it
um
but business Analytics
more business analysis more essential
than ever and the reason is that in the
last several years as we've been in the
grip of the
pandemic the coveted pandemic that has
caused various lockdowns and moved to
work from home or work remote
um
non-contact delivery of goods and
services
so much of our Lives has transferred
into the digital domain it's a trend
that's been going on
for decades now but as the pandemic
rolled out it accelerated the trend
um extremely rapidly and so businesses
now not only have
more data contacts data touch points
with customers digital touch points
through online ordering
through internet of things and through
other
aspects of the digital world but they
also
have more of their business models in
the digital domain
and
that means that they have both the need
and the opportunity to extract insights
and guidance from this sea of digital
information that's coming in
Professor or if you would can you
comment on
that trend
and what you're seeing
yeah sure sure as you can I keep it out
so uh to save about talks with industry
forward so say we had industrial one
with maybe Advent of our ability to
harness maybe a mechanical motion and uh
two with the say electric three but the
uh programmable logical controllers and
uh now uh say we have iot
industrial internet of things and uh as
you can actually said we are drowning in
the sea of uh information so sensors
actuation they are regulars uh you can
sense demand in Reading streets and uh
sends a lot of other information uh
store that information in a distributed
fashion in the central fashion process
it uh centrally you already distributed
manner but then I think uh the key
challenge is what do you do with it so
how do you are you able to extract uh
insights and uh then put those insights
to use cases in the business
um and uh yeah that's very important and
not trivial by any means so that does
require say lots of thought and
increasingly we are seeing use cases
surfacing validated use cases being
reported from industry from businesses
um so so it's an exciting space to watch
out
thank you for that um
so
this means that there's a huge demand
for people who can help businesses
do the translation of data into insights
data is not
data is not necessarily information
except in the theoretical sense
it becomes information when we relate it
to some context
business or policy making
but the information then only becomes
useful when we can draw insights from it
and so business analytics means that you
have a number of different open roles
here's just a few
business analysts
currently draw a an average salary of
8.5 lock annually in the
project managers
about six o'clock a year a data analyst
about five and
those are average salaries those do not
represent the upper limit of what's
available to you nor do they represent
the upper limit of what careers are
available to you because from a business
analyst role it's possible to move into
many other roles within the organization
and up within the field into
more advanced data science roles as well
so
business analytics is a great starting
point for a career it's a great
point for branching into many different
aspects of
both business and data science and it's
I think the reason why everyone is here
on this webinar today to talk about
the opportunities again if uh Professor
if you have any comments on the types of
other roles and career paths that you
see available to people please feel free
to jump in with that yeah and
increasingly we're seeing this trend so
like saying conventionally we'd have
these verticals of say marketing Finance
HR it's increasingly companies uh
initially people are not sure I say
companies how to go about uh handling
data so now in fact several companies
are choosing to have a separate vertical
altogether perhaps a data warehouse and
then a dedicated team a vertical which
is sort of a central resource but all
the different branches be marketing HR
because everything is getting impacted
by data and you can do with it ranging
from say machine learning artificial
intelligence prescriptive analysis
exploratory analysis uh so increasingly
There Are Rules within the business uh
across the supply chains be it say paid
manufacturer Logistics inbound outbound
retailer wholesaler warehouse management
so uh it seems to be a duplicate this
but of course A lot of it is of course
um uh it's I think settling down now
initially has been quite a quite a bit
of hype around that but nonetheless
um the the whatever remains it's also
quite substantive and it's in
increasingly getting consolidated
and so this is an opportunity to enter
into a great field
but to do that you need the the skill
set that will let you uh be effective as
a business analyst
a whole list of different types of
skills that you need to be exposed to in
business analytics is a catch-all for
that that includes descriptive
statistics prescriptive statistics
predictive statistics all of the
techniques that are used to look at
patterns and data and either describe
what is going on
predict what will go on in the future
based on extrapolation from past or
provide prescriptive
advice to a business about what changes
you can make to influence that future
data analytics and the data science
behind that is important data
visualization is very important because
the product of the business now analog
pardon me business analysis process
has to be communicated to Executives
managers and decision makers within an
organization
visualization dashboards making the
trends and
prescriptions
visually
understandable is an important skill
as is just a storytelling storyboarding
being able to show
where Trends come from and where the
future will be influenced
the techniques of linear and logistic
regression
statistics are important
um
being able to do hypothesis testing and
looking at
how changes in data would may change
future trends
being able to do uh
aggregations
being able to predict
put together presentation dashboards and
other types of systems that the end
users can access on their own so that
you don't have to hand hold them through
every time
they access the insights all of these
skills very important and create the
basis for a successful this analysis
career
um
is there anything you want to add to
that professor yeah as you correctly
mentioned it's a full Continuum of
skills so that it's mostly the rules are
issued by different people so you need
somebody who has a really deep
understanding of the business process
which probably gets impacted
incrementally or to seductively by say
business analytics intervention and then
yeah eventually maybe the high level
decision makers they require information
to be fed to them in a manner which is
easily assimilatable they can see which
is palatable so that's where I say these
fantastic visualizations you can plot
maybe thousands and tens and thousands
of points in a very neat graphic which
is very very information rich and again
this entire dish so you need people who
have expertise in business process to
begin to ask the right kind of questions
and at the same time then you need some
depth into the various categories of the
the skills the techniques a bit say
machine learning uh trying to analyze
patterns trying to predict trying to
forecast and then in turn use that
information in for decision making made
for some optimization kind of outcomes
so so what if you know how things are
going to turn out so uh so it's a nice
mix of competences and Company
competence that is required and uh the
rules are more often than not assumed by
different categories of people but it's
not say a one rule which will satisfy
somebody would be say have more depth in
business process they in turn require
some insight some view of what happens
on say the the method side of things but
then you do require people who are say
more deep in the methods and then they
work together and then that's the entire
continuum
yeah and again
this breadth of skills is the type of
thing that gives you a kind of a broad
Foundation to build on and you can dig
deeper into any particular skill area
that that is of most interest to you or
where you have the most aptitude so that
you have both the breadth and the depth
but at this point I'm going to ask a
question of the audience
first question is
what has prevented you from enrolling in
some type of program that would get you
these skills up to date if we assume
you're here because you're interested in
creating this kind of career and
learning how to do it
why haven't you done that up to date so
you can pick one two three or four of
these answers
um if you're watching and streaming you
can code them as A B C or D in your chat
or comment box
I'll leave the poll open for just a few
more seconds
as the answers come in
all right we'll close the poll in about
three seconds from now
two one
and
so for the people on WebEx you can see
that the by far the most popular answer
in this poll is you don't think that you
would end up with practical experience
that would
make you job ready and and let you prove
to an employer that you are job ready
for the position
um and then people have
also cited each of the other reasons so
let's
talk about a particular way to gain that
kind of practical experience and that is
through uh the program with IIT group
business analytics for strategic
decision making
which is a boot camp style program of
six months in duration it's
collaboration with isbm and it also
includes
live
virtual classes every week
that will allow you to interact with
your instructors and your classmates the
cohort is delivered entirely online you
can access the course materials other
than the live classes at any time on a
24x7 basis so you are able to schedule
your homework and your project
anytime that's convenient for you that
makes it very flexible and compatible
with your work and life demands
um it includes integrated case studies
and Hands-On projects that you do on the
integrated digital platform so that all
of that is done for you know available
to you in the virtual environment
without having to go to other places
systems or or pieces of software and
that the curriculum which we will go
through today is very comprehensive
covers all of the skill areas that we
spoke about
and this is a digital boot camp
um
different from a
in-person boot camp which would normally
lock you in a room with the instructors
and peers for some number of weeks of
intensive uh eight hour a day training
uh this digital boot camp is delivered
in a different way and requires about 10
to 15 hours a week including the live
virtual classes
um a devoted time so you can fit it much
more easily into
the job the lifestyle of a working
ethanol
um we can talk a bit about the learner
outcomes
what you'll get out of the program
the end of the program you receive a
certificate if you buy IIT Berkey
um
certifying that you have completed the
program and all of its core
uh
courses successfully
you also earn along the way certificates
from IBM for the courses that they
present as part of this program
you receive access to other IBM content
hackathons ask me anything sessions
master classes with the IBM
professionals
and uh along the way and for six months
afterward you receive a job assist
career assistance from Simply learning
Partners so this is a program that's
designed to give you the evidence you
can show to employers that you are
qualified for a business analytics role
and it helps you make that case to
employers
conduct your job search so
I'd like the professor to speak about
Professor Sherman if you could speak
about
IIT rookie is an institution
yeah absolutely uh so the picture that
you see is the main building of our
institution
um that's where a series tutors run from
that's where the administration sits and
it is in fact a very iconic uh building
for historical reasons in fact the CIA
we are celebrating uh the 175th year of
its uh Foundation uh it is in fact one
of the first engineering colleges in in
South Asia
um and uh yeah I encourage you to visit
the website of institution and you'll
find a lot more information about the
various departments we currently have
nine thousand uh students on campus it's
a fully residential campus and a little
more than 500 faculty uh who uh work
across I think 22 departments plus some
additional centers including dentists
for data science
Department of management studies and
computer science and all the other
conventional departments and uh
um so the management studies Department
that's where I think most of the faculty
offering this program are a base stat
um uh is in fact ranked first in the
research and professional practices in
2020
and um
we have a program uh the modules will be
covered by different faculty members who
all of them are experts in their
respective domains so we'll have some
code modules on say foundations of
business analytics some statistical
analysis for business decision making uh
I could I could name the name all the
modules but generally the philosophy is
we begin with say the concept there's
some Theory some some Concepts then some
Hands-On and um then we learn the
integrities of the mathematical or
statistical implementation and then we
learn to execute it in some sub software
uh beta XL beta read python uh so you
learn some programming languages and
then there's some Hands-On uh training
for you to maybe uh to deal with some
real life problems and get some insights
um and uh again uh has already been told
to you there's a mix of say maybe a
weekend uh live session some peer
assignments uh so we hope to deliver
some program and again
um
um uh to cater uh so it's it's designed
to be self-contained so even if you have
limited exposure in the respective
domains uh so we hope uh that it
satisfies sort of it caters to a broad
broad audience
um and again you can then take a deep
dive uh in terms of the functional
module spaces your respecting experience
thank you
um we'd also like that I am going to
mention the the
parallel advantage of our partnership
with IBM
part of the the content are courses
developed by IBM uh for in-depth
training in specific Technologies our
programming and python for data science
specifically so as you take these
modules
along the way you'll earn certificates
issued by IBM which are also again
internationally recognized and you'll
also have the option to take master
classes from IBM and participate in the
hackathons and ask me anything sessions
so you can interact with the people who
are Professionals in the industry and
get insights and and
interaction there so we're very proud
that that's part of this program as well
um and then I'll mention the simply
learn job assist service
simply learn as delivery partner with
IIT rookie for this program
also gives to Learners in India
specifically the
services that allow you to focus your
job search and be successful it's not a
job guarantee program it is or a job
placement program it is a job search
assist program
we offer access to expert webinars
career events things like that which are
free and ongoing for as long as you wish
farming on the end of the program we
have uh as part of the program real
world projects across industries that
build you a perform a portfolio
that give gives you something to point
to for real experience in business
analytics and we give you uh Services
through IIM jobs or access to an
exclusive job portal which allows you to
get your applications in
sooner and with more
exclusivity to a certain set of jobs but
we think as important or more important
are the resume review and rewrite
service
that a resumes go through an automated
tracking system and AI
bot will look at the content of the
resume
match it to job descriptions and only
pass through the resumes that it finds
are conformed to the rules and
requirements set by the system so
it's important to have a resume that is
in the format compatible with those
automated systems but which also appeals
to the eye of the human who will see it
on the other side if it makes it through
that first step so
resume review and rewrite kind of an art
form and we give you access to
someone who will Mentor you through that
and help you through that to get your
resume into its best possible form
similarly we offer interview services
to give you coaching career advice and
practice with one-on-one session
that allows you to practice different
types of interviews both the technical
interviews that cover the skills of the
particular job area but also the soft
skills interviews that
well to show that you're a team player
that you understand how organizations
work
that you're fit for
work in a corporate environment both
types of interviews pardon me both types
of interviews are extremely important to
go through several rounds so
this type of practice session is
very valuable to you to put your best
base to
people who are going to hire you
I mentioned the the webinars and other
events we conduct webinars in this type
of format that we're doing today but
focused on
industry friends
job opportunity trends
the skills for a job search
um some of them are mini lessons in
technical topics so all of these are
free conducted by simply learn and
access them
um
throughout your career if you like
and the projects that you will do within
this program become as I mentioned part
of your portfolio so these are a few
examples of the the types of projects
you can work on
looking at product mix optimization and
you think uh business analytics to
determine which sets of project products
um a best fit your sales patterns
um and your supply chains
looking at smart consumption energy
domain and looking at how seasonality
and and other Trends affect
consumption and
planning ahead for the supply to those
consumers customer segmentation to
understand the customer personality
um looking at people in the HR domain
look at uh
how
consumers of an HR System
interact with it how to characterize
them into different personality types
all of these types of projects and more
become things that you can demonstrate
to potential employers this is the
problem I was
chose to solve and this is how I solved
it
it's extremely valuable
to become eligible for this program
do not have to have prior technology
experience
or know-how
you do have to have a drive and aptitude
to apply business analytics Concepts to
real world problems
and this is intended for working
professionals so it is preferred that
you have at least six years of
experience in the in the workforce not
necessarily as a business analyst or in
data science or that type of thing but
just six years of actual working
experience out in the real world
so that you understand how organizations
work and really where businesses might
require
the use of business
analytics so with that said I would like
to I think another poll question
and this poll question relates to what
we just talked about which is how much
experience do you have in the workplace
get a feel for who's in the audience so
Professor Sharma can see that
and here is the poll result
so we have uh about 40 of our audience
are folks in the
third two-year category we have
uh another 15 two to five years and that
means that there is about 35 percent of
the audience who are
more than five years six or more years
of experience
um again this is a program that's open
to all
uh possibly geared a little bit more to
the more experienced folks but
wanna
hear about the rest of it if you're in
the
first two categories here so let me move
on
I want to ask a question
of one of our guests here
is that you Professor amut if it is
please unmute yourself
all right
uh that might not be him um Okay so
oh where did Professor Sharma go
um so how this program prepares you
we are managing uh your curriculum
through the
um
live
online learning management system
environment
it is digitally delivered it's available
to you uh on your desktop or laptop
device or most of your classwork but you
can access the material anywhere you are
on a mobile device as well
and the live virtual classroom is best
experienced of course on the laptop but
um
the live virtual classroom is
eight hours of instruction
live session
actually two four hour sessions on the
weekends
you can do your Labs tests case studies
through the
digital online environment
um
the Capstone project which I'll describe
in more detail
uh is essentially taking all of your
skills that you've learned in the course
and putting them together into
final project that
solves a real world business problem
and allows you to show how you each of
the skills in the program
to solve it
the system of course keeps track of your
progress it allows you to go through the
curriculum in the correct stepwise order
unlocking each course as you finish the
one before it and giving you access to
certificates when you successfully
complete the different courses in the
the full course full program
along the way also includes the support
tools to ask questions of your
instructors to ask questions of our
support staff both about the platform
but also about the course material and
to interact with your peers
so that you have a community bulletin
board to ask other people in the course
about
um
you know I was working on this problem
what was your approach to it
because if you're working on something
at three o'clock in the morning and you
have a doubt or a blocker you're able to
turn to somebody whether it's up here
whether it's one of our support staff or
whether it's your professor posed that
question and get an answer reasonably
quickly to be able to keep going in your
work
and
you also have access to the library of
on-demand video content that supplements
the course
any class files that your instructors
have put together
for the work that you're doing so all of
that is available to you
learning management system libraries
we talked about the curriculum and
Professor Sharma mentioned that briefly
um
so business Analytics
for decision making starts with the
orientation session which basically
talks to you about
what to expect how to use learning
management system what the schedules
will be and then from that you move on
to the foundations of data analytics
which is
as it says a foundational course that
gives you an overview and basic
understanding of the field
move into statistical analysis the
mathematical principles behind business
Analytics
and looking into how to do exploratory
data analysis and visualization using
the r programming language which is a
key tool for data science
then moving on to Predictive Analytics
to be able to say from past experience
this is the pattern we see and the trend
we see going forward
prescriptive analytics which says based
on these patterns and our the trends
we're seeing what our policy decisions
that might get to our goals
faster and easier
and
finally design data science and this
machine learning for decision making so
looking more into advanced topics and
the
automated Technologies involved in
Analytics
finally the culmination as I mentioned
the Capstone project takes from all of
the courses
lets you uh integrate and synthesize
that into your final project for the
program
which becomes essentially
the basis on which you are graded and
passed the program
along the way you can take academic
master classes with IIT rookie faculty
industry master classes from IBM
you can study data analysis with python
from IBM you can look at mathematical
optimization of business problems which
is another IBM course and data
visualization of python
um all of these electives are included
in the cost of the program so you don't
have to uh pay anything extra to take
any of the electives you can choose
whether to take them based on your time
availability and your level of Interest
that's the program's internals and the
tools and Frameworks you'll be exposed
to include
first Excel but also Tableau power bi
from Microsoft
Python and R MySQL various other tools
platforms and Frameworks that will then
be able to cite in your resume as these
are tools I've used not just because
I've seen them or been exposed to them
but I've actually used them in my
projects during this program so very
powerful
and
the Capstone project also is extremely
powerful which is why we've mentioned it
several times you get to choose
problem in a particular domain
have several to choose from and you'll
be able to say this is the one I want to
work on spend several weeks
working
with weekly mentoring sessions with you
instructor
will help keep you on track and help you
avoid
dead ends and blockers and you'll come
up with
the solution that you will build and
code yourself
to be able to demonstrate that you've
solved the problem
in your own particular way
that becomes part of your permanent
portfolio so not only is it sent over to
be evaluated and granted
part of the
program itself but it's also something
that you can expose to
potential employers
the
what you accomplished what your skill
level is
um
Professor Sharma
Professor Ami
and Professor Ramesh are both
the advisors in the program all of these
are professors in the department of
management studies at IIT rookie some of
them will be teaching modules within the
program
and or master classes and uh
the this is the program it's delivered
by simply learned but it's
designed and over seen by IIT murkey
So based on what we have said so far
I'd like to know
uh are you
interested let me get the poll question
going
are you interested in taking this course
based on this thumbnail sketch that
we've
exposed you to
again you put yes or no into your
comments if you're on the
streaming services
and we'll leave this open for just about
15 seconds
about five seconds more
and here is the full result
about three quarters of our audience are
interested in taking the course that's
great I'm going to talk to you now about
how to accomplish that
of the enrollment steps
so for those of you interested start by
sending an email to us here at simply
learn ask us at simplylearn.net we
administer this program for IIT rookie
um submit the application you may be
contacted for more information about
your background
information about your aptitude and
interest in business Analytics
and all that will be taken into
consideration
if
ask the application review and
we believe that you have the
uh
aptitude the desire and the ability to
succeed with this program will offer you
admission
the next cohort starts oh
of the wrong start date here um the
orientation was a couple days ago but
you can still join this cohort uh the
26th of November because there will be
another orientation
um the classes themselves start the 26th
of November
the cost of the program is one lock
sixty nine thousand
which you can get financed with no
cost financing at 56 10 a month
so this is a way for you to make the
program more affordable in your budget
you if you are doing this for a current
employer
you can ask them about tuition
reimbursement some companies have that
policy
but in the meantime we encourage you to
email us at ask us at simplylearn.net
we'll move into the question and answer
period so
Professor Sharma has
fortunately
been called away
let me make sure I
see that correctly
and I want to know if the
participant I meet is that you Professor
Amit
if it is you can unmute yourself
okay I think I've got the different
individual so I'm going to go ahead with
the questions and answers that have come
in so far
and
facilitate that I'm going to stop
sharing the presentation for a moment
and see the other
okay we have covered the fees
okay
all right I'm looking to see I don't see
any questions in the chat
looking in the Q a here
what is prescriptive statistics garov
asks the question
prescriptive statistics
um so we we talked about descriptive
predictive and prescriptive
descriptive statistics say
can we build a model that accurately
describes what has happened in the past
so for example if we're looking at the
problem of global warming
the climate scientists want to model
the
temperature of the climate
based on a factor like atmospheric CO2
you would use descriptive statistics
to create a model and check it against
the
data that you've collected from The Real
World cast
um if your model is accurate is to say
if model conforms with what was actually
measured
then you can move on to the next phase
which is
predictive statistics and predictive
statistics would say okay if this is the
way that
the climate has reacted in the past the
changes it's in a variable and we see
what the variable is trending currently
what can we what do we expect will
happen
in The Next Century what is the future
hold if the trends for that variable
continue that will give you a pers
predictive model of what will happen
and then you move on to
if we want to change that outcome
create a different outcome
what do we need to do in order to reach
this other desired goal so it's a
prescriptive statistics say if our new
goal is X then how do we change variable
Y what policies do we have to take in
order to
make this happen
so that's the
type of thing and this course supplies
the business problems as well in terms
of for example if and model the supply
chain
Its Behavior in the past and you see
where it's going
on current trends into the future then
you can come up with prescriptions for
how to change things so that you avoid
supply chain problems
future
so
uh
okay uh Rika asked a question about the
financing uh financing as low as 56.30
uh the financing extends from more than
the six months of the program the
financing extends until the entire
program fee is paid so it is not a
56 56 30 per month for six months it's
56.30 so that you can extend the
payment period over a longer period of
time and keep it in your budget I just
want to make that clear because the
question did come up
uh does this program help move me into
the I.T sector for a career change
uh Sunil this is probably not
the program to move into the I.T sector
business analytics is an application of
Information Technology and data science
so you're moving more into the data
science sector and into the business
sector through a program like this into
the I.T sector there are other programs
and you can also check simplylearn's own
website simply.com
see some of the other programs we offer
in that
um are both David asked a question which
is as data analysts and business analyst
the same in nature in the same type of
thing uh yes data analysts and business
analysts do similar work
data analysts
business analysts is a subset of data
anal put it that way
specifically taking skills of data
analytics and applying them to the
business context and business problems
so you get more of an emphasis on how
will business decision makers use the
Data Insights from the data from
business analytics uh the analytics uh
is more General it can be applied to
many other things probably
for example solving the
issue of climate change or advising
policy makers you would use business
analytics techniques
specifically you'd use more General data
analytics techniques
because the problem you're solving is
not a business problem on the other hand
if you are a business
and your goal is to
create policies that are compatible with
environmental constraints and
requirements being handed down by your
national government then a business
analyst would help you
look at
those constraints and that problem in
the context of what your business can do
about it how your business must adapt to
it
what jobs are fair uh I'm a minor asks
what jobs are favorable to help me grow
in this field so again you would start
off with uh
hopefully from this program a business
analytics job which then opens up
a career path within business analysis
but it also lets you get exposed to
other
vertical functions within a business and
move up that way so you might end up
as a operations manager after some years
of experience in the business as a
business analyst
um
what are the opportunities for people
with 15 plus years of experience in IT
project management so this takes your
capabilities and
your understanding of I.T gives you a
leg up in terms of technology and the
technical aspects of this program but it
also gives you a leg up in terms of
understanding a particular domain so for
example you might
find yourself qualified
to um
the more effective CIO because you
understand the trends
um and the business analytics behind
managing an I.T project department so
this is the type of thing that broadens
your skills and you can
either use it to Pivot into a different
business domain or apply it in the same
domain of I.T
um
so
ridicu returns to the question uh you
have to pay the full uh one lock 69 000
but installments uh that is correct you
have the option of paying it off in
installments okay
um are you suggesting in private sector
uh I mean yes this is uh
business analytics can be applied both
in the private and the public sector
public sector
problems often extend beyond the domain
of business analytics type but many
public sector agencies have uh
an orientation toward
Public Service as a customer service
type of arrangement
and they view delivery of their services
and the business sense
a public utility for example has to deal
with energy consumers and delivering
their product to the consumer so there
are opportunities in the public sector
for business analysts as well
um
and let me return to the other stream of
questions here
hold on for a moment as I pull that up
does the course include Python
Programming at what level so the the
course includes a elective on Python
program which is fairly basic
um but it equips you to use python
in data science applications and
business analytics so it's
uh not a
not a
firmer or an overview it is a rigorous
course that will give you that skill
uh is the program for students only in
India uh generally speaking yes this is
oriented towards students in India so
this is why we don't quote the price in
US Dollars it is possible to take the
course from anywhere but it is
primarily devoted to people in India and
the job assist services are exclusive to
to Learners in India
um are people with no experience in just
graduating not even eligible for this
course you are eligible uh you will want
to talk to one of the job counselors via
ask us at simplylearn.net
in order to determine if you'll be at a
disadvantage or whether you have the
required aptitude
and ability to succeed in the course
it's important that
to be honest with yourself about your
willing to dead willingness to dedicate
the time and also um
your your level of understanding
Readiness so that you're
investing in something that will help
you succeed in your career and not
something that will frustrate you
um how many Capstone projects
there is one required Capstone project
in the program it takes several weeks
three to four weeks to complete
you are welcome to do more than one
Capstone project
um
we will be sharing a recording of this
orientation
in a follow-up email
and
let me say
you got a question about when the next
cohort is available I'm going to put
into the chat for you right now a link
to the program page on our website along
with the ask us at simplylearn.net
email address
and what you can find out from that
website is you'll be able to see the
uh
upcoming dates for the different cohorts
but also you can ask that question by
emailing us that ask us at
simplylearn.net and they'll be able to
inform you about
what dates are upcoming and how often
you cohorts start
looking at
coming up at the end of the hour so
what is the duration of the program six
months
it takes you through in a stepwise
fashion the set of courses that I showed
in that curriculum slide
you have to complete each one
before the next one gets unlocked and it
becomes available to you so you do go
through step by step in a given sequence
um
to ask a great question which is
not saying any of the other questions
are not great but this one catches my
interest because he's starting up in
agriculture based company
how will this course help
the in any company you need to be able
to do things like look at forecasts for
sales
um if you're doing an agriculture based
company you may be looking at more
General forecasts of climate crop yields
how planting seasons will be affected
all of those types of things and being
able to make your own
judgments based on your own analytics
may help you get an advantage over other
companies in the same field
there's so much data
especially understanding the data that's
being collected by
um
AG tech systems
even small farmers in India are
reporting conditions through a
smartphone interface
getting advice back in that fashion so
there's a lot of data coming in from
many many data points
and depending on the business that
you're starting up
you may want to be able to access that
from public sources do your own analysis
of what that means for your products and
services
uh humans should ask for clarification
is the program of simple learning a 100
job guarantee and I want to be clear
that no this is not a job guarantee
program we offer job assistance to help
Focus you and assist you with your job
search
your success in your job search based on
your effort we give you help and tools
along the way but we do not guarantee
that you will complete that
um
I do not have exposure in mathematics as
a subject but I have good corporate
exposure
um so Brown I would say that you
probably want to ask
the learning Consultants ask us at
simplylearn.net and get evaluated for
the kind of course material you'll be
exposed to to make sure that
you can understand the concepts being
presented statistics is a mathematical
science
you want to make sure that you're not
going to get into the class find it
frustrating for you
cause you to leave the program because
that's that's not a satisfactory outcome
for you or anyone else for IIT rookie or
simply learn
um
and
Cora I think the last question we can
take time we have is
how
you do the data collection we haven't
talked about collection of raw data
that is one of the things that's
discussed
in the courses about where do you Source
the data
the data for the courses themselves are
sample data sets that are pre-assembled
for the courses and the projects
but there will be discussion of how in
the real world would you go about
setting up a data collection data
induction data conditioning
we do there are other courses that uh
you can take on data engineering that
are outside the scope of this program
but uh it's also a fascinating field
usually business analysts have
data sources that are set up
by other folks in the company but again
understanding
where those things could come from and
how they can be collected is
part of this course so
with that I'm going to
complete with one last question for our
audience
and if I didn't get to your question I
apologize
here is our final poll questions for the
audience polling
here we go
so about three quarters of you said that
you were interested in enrolling in the
program and
when would you like to start are you
interested in getting into that cohort
that starts
uh in about a week or so
are you looking at one after that
is something that you look at
further in the future
we always say that if this is something
that is worth doing because it will
impact your career and your life
positively
consider doing it sooner than later
and about 10 percent of our audience
uh would like to get started with that
cohort that starts later this month
please email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net for that
um
about another 35 percent third or so
want to get involved maybe in the cohort
right after that one so again please
email us and for the rest of you
um suggest that you send us an email
just to keep track of what's going on
ask your questions about the program
find out what
schedules might be happening in the
future
and with that I'm going to
thank you everyone who's been here today
for being in our streaming audiences and
our live WebEx audience
we remind you to ask us at
simplylearn.net to find out more
information about the program I will
again put that into the chat
again
we thank you for being here we hope this
has helped you
and we look forward to
inviting you into the IIT roorkee
learning community
so with that that concludes our webinar
for today